hey guys max welcome to our step-by-step
build guide where I'm going to show you
exactly how you can build a full gaming
PC for only $350 even if you've never
built one before now I'm gonna be
upfront with you guys all of the parts
that I chose here we're chosen for one
reason they are inexpensive because
trust me it is extremely hard to make a
PC for 303 bucks but it can be done as
you guys will see and as always we have
all the links to these parts in the
video description along with alternative
links because prices do go up and down
things go out of sale so the prices you
guys see might be a little bit different
and then we'll also have some
alternatives and suggestions if you have
a little bit more money to spend on what
you could do to get better performance
at the heart of this build we have two
AMD CPUs that are brand spanking new we
have the new 3100 and the 3300 ex now
for the 350 our build that you'll see
we're using the 3100 it is only $99 and
has four cores a threads brand-new seven
nanometer it's a great CP for the money
and if you're gonna have a little bit
more money to spend you're gonna get our
recommended graphics card upgrade then
we will say spend the extra $20 on the
3300 X which does have better gaming
performance next I have 8 gigabytes of
ddr4 Ram just one stick for this 350 our
build and then I also have a small m2
SSD because it is just super easy to
install now I'm going with just one
stick that way later on when you have an
extra 35 bucks you can go ahead and get
another stick and then you're gonna get
a little more performance out of it and
a little bit more overall ram just so
that we're not locked in a spur that SSD
this is definitely not gonna hold a ton
of games but it's gonna give you a quick
system fast boot ups and then if you
want to get a regular spinning hard
drive you could do that or maybe upgrade
to a larger one the power supply and the
motherboard we're both chosen because
they are inexpensive that's the main
thing the motherboard still has some
good features so you're not going to be
you know too limited and the power
supply the one I have here is slightly
different than the one I'm linking to
just because I had this on hand but
we're going to the budget option because
we're reaching that really cheap price
point and along with that I'm not gonna
you know lie to you guys this is a very
cheap case
because we had to get a cheap one for
the price point but it does have a side
window so you can see your parts inside
it also has a USB 3.0 port it's a
headphone jack a couple other USB ports
so you do get some features with it and
lastly the graphics card it's important
for gaming this one is an AMD 560 it was
chosen because of the price point and as
I mentioned we do have alternatives down
below with some suggestions if you can
stretch your budget just a little bit
and I do have actually somewhere down
here my recommended graphics card for
about $80 more which is not that much
more which is the 580 that will give you
quite a bit better performance let's go
ahead and jump into the build the first
thing I want to do if you don't have an
anti-static strap is touch a metal
object make sure you don't have any
static electricity built up and we're
gonna go ahead and get started by hot
placing the motherboard on the mother
bird box is a good surface to work off
of and I'm going to be putting almost
everything on the motherboard before we
pop it in so here we have our CPU you do
not want to touch these bottom pins they
can get bent easily be very careful also
don't touch the top you don't else on
there and there's a little lever on the
CPU socket so we're gonna pull out a
little bit and then pull up to release
and unlock and on the CPU there's a
little triangle in the corner and that
tells you how to place it into the CPU
socket there's a little triangle up here
as well so I'm gonna twist this and then
very carefully align it and it should
just drop right in and then now I'm
gonna grab this lever push it down and
lock it and now we're gonna attach the
cooler we're using the one that's
included with the CPU you definitely
don't need to spend extra money works
good enough and we do have thermal paste
so you don't want to touch that and this
will actually screw into the motherboard
and our motherboard already has some
other mounts on here so I'm gonna go
ahead and just unscrew these and now I'm
gonna go ahead and align our screws with
the little sockets over here you want to
make sure that when you set it down you
don't start moving a side to side
because you don't want to smear the
thermal paste so what I do is I align
the backs and then slowly lower it down
and now I'm going to start by screwing
down one side I'm not going to do it all
the way I'm going to do just enough to
get it started then I'm going to go to
the opposite side here get that one
going and then
after each one has been threaded in then
I'll slowly go and just tighten it all
down just we want even pressure on this
and now let's plug in the cpu fan
connector it's right up top here labeled
CPU fan one now let's install the m2 SSD
you want to get out the little screw
that came in the baggy and the your
motherboard box your m2 SSD has a couple
notches cut out but it will only go in
one way so don't force it and typically
it's gonna be the label side up so I'm
going to attach it plug it in at an
angle then we're gonna push it down and
align up with this little spot for the
screw and we'll just screw that down
just enough to get the screw to stop now
let's go ahead and install our RAM
oftentimes I actually do this inside of
the case but just to make it easier to
show you guys I'm going to do outside if
you do outside you could still install
the motherboard later just makes a
little bit difficult with a couple of
the screws but let's go ahead and get
started as I mentioned at the start we
just have one stick of RAM this is 8
gigs that's because it's less expensive
than getting 2 4 gig sticks and that
helps us reach our price point and in
the future you can add another gig to
get to 16 so you get a little more
flexibility but you might get slightly
lower performance with just one stick
out of the get-go I'm gonna go ahead
install it in this right-hand slot so
I'm going to open this up just on this
end and on the stick there's actually a
little cutout a little notch and that's
gonna match up with the little notch
inside of the RAM slot we're gonna align
the stick with the slots and I'm just
gonna have you know push down with EB
pressure on both ends and you guys heard
and that clicking I saw it actually get
locked in place and now I'm gonna set
the motherboard and everything else
aside I'm gonna grab our case and we're
gonna get this prepped up for the
motherboard so we're gonna start out by
taking off these thumb screws with a
side panel both the front one and the
rear one the first thing I'm gonna do is
I'm going to carefully lower down this
motherboard and I'm gonna see if the
standoffs basically little points and
we're going to be screwing the
motherboard down to line up with these
holes so as you guys might see we have
couple up here and then we have four
more over here so let's go ahead and
drop it in carefully it looks like
almost everything matches up the top to
match
up these three match up and then just
this one right here you guys might see
the standoff is slightly lower so now I
know I only have to adjust one of them
yep I can just unscrew with my hand if
it's too tight most cases will have a
little a tool to remove it or you can
use some pliers and I'm just gonna screw
it in to the one right above that and
now we're gonna pop in our IO shield you
do want to be careful because the edges
are sharp and the little three holes for
your audio inputs and outputs they're
gonna be at the bottom so you can go
ahead and just press it against the back
panel and then apply pressure on one
side than the other to get it to block
in let's go ahead and drop this back
down and now we can go ahead and install
our motherboard just like before I'm
going to carefully lower it down but now
we have the i/o shield so that we want
to make sure that we don't push anything
in make sure everything's aligned
properly and then you have to apply a
light pressure to get it to pop in we're
gonna set it down you'll want to grab
six of the smaller screws that are
included with your little baggie and
then we're gonna screw down this
motherboard at the six points we have
four here at the bottom and then two at
the top and magnetic screwdriver really
helps with this and now we're gonna
connect our case to the motherboard we
have these three separate cables this
one the biggest one is USB 3.0 it's easy
these other two are easy as well but I'm
gonna do it after I get these done these
little ones are the toughest you have a
bunch of small ones they are all labeled
and if you bought the same motherboard
that we did on page 16 you're gonna have
a guide that shows you exactly where
they need to be plugged in the
motherboard also does have some markings
but they are quite small and this part
is just really hard to show on camera so
I'm just gonna plug these in as they are
label check out your motherboard and
your owner's manual and you'll see
exactly where to pop them in that's that
plugged right over here next I'm going
to do our USB 3.0 cable there's a little
notch over here so you can't insert it
the wrong way
that's aligning right there I'm gonna
line that and then push in and then the
last one is USB and audio our audio is
right over here in the bottom left hand
side and then if you take a look at the
panes there is one missing and that
shows you how to plug it in
just all the pins match up I'm gonna go
ahead and split the cable because our
USB port is on the other side and that
will plug in and our USB plugs in right
down here next to the USB 3.0 if you
want to do a little bit of a cleaner job
on the inside instead of plugging them
in as they come from the case you can
run the cables and wires through the
back and then through one of these
little cutouts just to make it a little
bit cleaner but we have a lot of extra
space and I'm just gonna do some cable
management later and now we are gonna
install our power supply so I'm gonna
lift up our case here grab our power
supply and I'm gonna insert this from
the inside over here just slide it in
and then line up the holes I'll go ahead
and insert it and I want to tuck it
underneath this little metal bracket
that stands out and you want to line up
the holes here where we're gonna put our
little bolts into I'll grab four of the
larger ones from our baggie and then we
can go ahead and align them and tighten
down our power supply and now we have a
mess of cables sticking out over here
and this case is not designed for good
cable management as you saw earlier all
the cables from the case come out the
top which makes it harder to manage but
we're gonna do what we can I split up
these cables into two sections so the
first one is our 24 pin and then we have
the one that's labeled CPU so that's
going to be important and then we have
one more for the graphics card labeled
PCI Express and then all these other
ones I'm gonna go ahead and just tuck
these into this hard drive tray if you
install both hard drives you won't be
able to but if you do just one you could
just put it in the lower slot now we are
going to need one of these molex
connectors for the fans and then if
you're going to do a standard hard drive
you will need one of these SATA power
cables so I'm going to pull one of these
all the way through because we're going
to use that and the rest I'll just tuck
in I'm gonna keep our graphics card
cable labelled PCI Express here on the
outside and these two I'm actually going
to go ahead and route them through this
little cutout that is right next to the
power supply on the right hand side just
to keep this a little bit cleaner
you guys can see that right over here
and I'll grab our 24
I'm gonna round it back in through this
table cut out closer to where we're
gonna plug it in and then the one that's
labeled CPU I normally would route it up
through here it is really tight on this
particular case if you have a different
case you upgraded it you'll have some
extra room so because I'm gonna route it
through the same slot and then we're
gonna just pull it up where we're gonna
plug it in and now I'll grab my rear fan
power cable and I wanted to feed it
through here but like I said before it's
just way too tight on this case usually
you do have room so I'm gonna just
unscrew the top two screws just so I
have a little bit of play here to route
it through and then I'll go ahead and
just pull that 4-pin molex connector and
cable to the back make sure you don't
forget to tighten those back up and now
I can go ahead and connect our PC case
fans to these four pin molex connectors
and then if you choose to spend a little
bit extra money on an LED strip or two
these things are very inexpensive we
have a link down below you can also
route that cable through and then we'll
also plug that in and then if you choose
to buy one of these very inexpensive LED
strips or two you can route that power
cable through the bottom slot over here
as well and then connect it to our 4-pin
molex right there and the last thing I
want to point out is we have this SATA
power connector as we push all these
cables in so if you're gonna have a
regular spinning hard drive you're gonna
use that to connect it thankfully our
back panel does have this little space
here for cables so that's nice one good
thing about this case now go ahead and
touch all these cables in and that
should be all for our cables on the back
and now let's get these cables connected
the first time I do is grab my LED strip
and just gonna tuck it in over here and
of course that's not in the 350 but I
think these turn out to be about five
bucks a pop or something like that so
we're gonna get that in and then we're
gonna connect our CPU power cable to the
motherboard so this action has eight
pins on this power supply it's already
together but the motherboard only needs
four so I'm going to separate these and
then that's gonna get connected right up
there at the top left and it only goes
in one way
and this will actually lock in to a
little piece that sticks
there so don't force it in line it up
and it should go in fairly easily I'm
gonna tuck this cable out of the way and
then our 24 pin also has a little lock
in it so this will curve will Bend it
like that and then push it does take a
little bit of force but you'll hear that
little click once it's locked in and now
finally let's install our graphics card
which is pretty much the most important
part for gaming Nevadan flip this case
over and we first need to remove this
little cover for our PCI slots and then
for our motherboard we're actually going
to be popping out this second a little
piece of metal and I'm actually gonna
pop the bottom one as well
I'm gonna go ahead and set this back
down and then on our PCI slot we have
this little lock so I'm going to push it
down to open it up and then you want to
insert this carefully these two sections
right here need to go between and the
case and the motherboard so line it up
don't force it down make sure it's lined
up to the slot all those pins and then
just apply a little bit of pressure and
then that lock will actually click up
once that's in place I'm gonna put this
little cover back on and u s-- line up
those pins if you have a larger and
heavier graphics card then you'll want
to screw it down first and then the
touch this cover but with these smaller
graphics cards you don't really need to
because this cover is gonna hold it
really well if you bought the exact
graphics card that we use there actually
isn't a place to plug in your power it
draws enough from the motherboard and
through the PCI Express slot but if you
take our advice and spend about $80 more
to get a lot more performance with one
of these five ATS you see we do have
connectors and so when that is installed
you'll go ahead and plug this in since
we don't need that I'm just gonna go
ahead and just tuck this in for later
use and lastly I'm gonna go ahead and
put the side panel back on a lot of
times I won't put it on I'll go ahead
and test it first beforehand just in
case something isn't popped in all the
way or screwed in all the way so I'll
just go ahead and take my chances this
time and put the cover on and now for
the moment of truth I'm going to plug in
our power cable and let us see
BAM they rehab it the fans are spinning
we have our LED light the CPU is
spinning as well excellent now let's go
ahead and connect our monitor our
keyboard and our mouse and now we can
restart our PC we're gonna watch for the
logo that pops up and then most
motherboards delete will work to get you
into the BIOS so I'm going to keep
hitting delete over here and BAM but we
are in and right here we see we have
eight gigs of RAM installed and then we
have our CPU installed
Rison three 3100 excellent let's go
ahead and look at our hardware monitor
here I'm gonna go ahead and shut the
system down I'm gonna grab my Windows 10
USB Drive I created this myself just by
going to Microsoft's website you can
actually legally download Windows 10 and
I'll even let you install it without
having a serial key you just have to
activate it later you can still use it
for a long time that way or you can buy
a license online or use the old one go
ahead and plug it in to our USB 3.0
slots and turn on the PC I'm gonna hit
f11 and that gets us to our boot menu
for this motherboard and actually
actually noticed Windows right away so
it's gonna be loading us into here and
from this point on you just follow these
step by step little sections to install
windows it's fairly easy if you don't
have a product here you just hit I don't
have a product key I'm gonna select
Windows 10 home since this is a new PC
build I'm gonna hit custom install and
here we'll see our SSD I'm gonna click
on it and hit next and right away it's
gonna start getting ready and installing
windows since we have an SSD and we have
a USB 3 thumb drive with the USB 3 ports
gonna solve fairly quickly as soon as
it's done you're just gonna hit your
normal Windows setup just like you
bought a PC from the store so that
part's fairly easy the next step you
want to do is plug in your PC to the
internet with an Ethernet cable or you
can buy a Wi-Fi card or even a Wi-Fi USB
adapter if you don't have a long cable
or you want to place it somewhere else
this one right here I'll link in the
video description it is very very cheap
if you're on the budget but it still
supports Wi-Fi 5 so you're gonna get
good speeds and then you just let
windows update
update and download all of the drivers
and from there you can start installing
your games thank you guys for watching
once again we have all the links in the
video description along with
alternatives just in case something is
sold out or the price went up and we'll
have some upgrades if you guys have a
little bit more money to spend
make sure you guys click that circle
above if you guys want to see us
actually gaming on this system we're
gonna have that video coming up soon
that's been maxed and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]